Die Antwort auf alles, das Leben, das Universum und alles ist...
Hallo, hier ist Chaos Radio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 56. Wir schreiten mal wieder schnell vor Baranen. Und der Grund dafür ist, dass ich derzeit in Wien weile, und zwar auf einer sehr interessanten Konferenz, die sich DeepSec nennt, eine neue Security-Konferenz, die hier in Europa gestartet ist. Und ja, so verwundert es auch nicht, dass das Thema dieser Sendung auch den Sicherheitsaspekt ein bisschen im Vordergrund hat. Und zwar möchte ich reden über GSM-Netzwerke, und wir wollen ein bisschen versuchen, immer herauszufinden, wie GSM-Netzwerke eigentlich wirklich funktionieren, und vor allem auch, was so der Stand der Dinge ist in Bezug auf die Sicherheit. Und insofern freue ich mich auch, einen kompetenten Gesprächspartner zu dem Thema zu haben. Ich begrüße Steve, hallo. Du hast ja heute hier einen Vortrag gehalten auf der Konferenz zu eben diesem Thema. Wie gefällt dir die Konferenz?
Die Konferenz an sich wunderbar organisiert. Schöne Leute hier, gutes Wissen. Mir gefällt besonders die Vorträge, die gehalten werden. Internationale Szene, super Spaß.
Ist das ein Novum für Europa aus deiner Sicht?
Die Konferenz, wie sie so läuft, ist einzigartig in Europa. Das gibt es bis jetzt noch nicht in Europa. Sehr schön, gut organisiert.
Ich habe den gleichen Eindruck bisher gehabt. Es ist eine sehr entspannte Atmosphäre hier in Wien. In Wien sowieso ist ja immer alles sehr entspannt. Das kommt sicherlich noch dem zu Gute. Man merkt eben auch diesen klaren Security-Fokus. Es gibt natürlich auch viele bekannte Gesichter, die man weltweit auf Security-Konferenzen sieht. Aber es ist, glaube ich, auch eine leicht andere Mischung, als man sie sonst vorfindet.
Ich bin mir sicher, dass es von DeepSec eine zweite Vision geben wird nächstes Jahr.
Das ist doch gut zu hören. Dann werden wir auch wieder da sein. Vielleicht mal kurz zu dir. Du bist auch schon eine Weile unterwegs mit Technologie und Coding und auch Security im Besonderen. Kannst du vielleicht mal kurz zu deinem Hintergrund was sagen?
Mein Name ist Steve und ich bin bei einer deutschen Hackergruppe, die sich THC nennt, die seit elf Jahren unterwegs ist. In den elf Jahren hat THC immer Sachen gemacht, die andere Leute nicht gemacht haben. Irgendwelche Sicherheitslücken auch spioniert oder irgendwo geschaut, was man mit Technologie anstellen kann, was man mit Telefon anstellen kann oder was man mit Computern alles anstellen kann.
Also es steht immer sehr security-orientiert auf?
Immer sehr security-orientiert.
Also sozusagen das klassische Hackerfeld. Das klassische Hackerfeld. Nicht so ein Politwischwasch, wie es sich dieses Thema macht.
Nein, nicht ein Politwischwasch. Wir haben die richtigen Sachen gemacht. Wir haben den Unix-Code geschrieben und verteilt.
Okay. Bevor man da Verwirrung stiftet, sollte man noch erläutern, THC steht für?
The Hacker's Choice. Und ursprünglich waren es nur deutsche Mitglieder, aber seit drei, vier Jahren haben wir auch internationale Mitglieder aus den Niederlanden, aus Vietnam und von überlost der Welt eigentlich. Und momentan sind wir 14 Leute im Team. Und ja, es ist sehr viel Spaß und wir versuchen immer neue Herausforderungen zu finden.
Okay. Eine dieser Herausforderungen scheint das GSM-Netzwerk zu sein, was ja das Thema deines Vortrages heute war. Da kam eine ganze Menge Detailwissen zur Sprache und das traf sich insofern ganz gut, als dass ich schon längere Zeit mal hier auch einen Express-Podcast geplant hatte zu dem Thema GSM. Ich würde ganz gerne mal ein bisschen erst mal eingehen darauf, wie eigentlich GSM-Netzwerke funktionieren. Ich meine, mittlerweile ist das überall, jeder hat irgendwie ein Telefon. Ich würde einfach ganz gerne mal ein bisschen verstehen, wie die Netzstruktur eigentlich aussieht, weil ja die mobile Anforderung schon anders ist als bei Festnetzen. Ich sage mal, da gibt es irgendwie keine Stecker, wo man Kabel reinsteckt, sondern da muss man sich irgendwie die Frequenzen teilen. Wie kann man denn da rangehen? Also was ist denn so das Herz eines GSM-Netzwerks? Was muss man denn als erstes, also wenn ich jetzt so ein leeres Land habe, sagen wir mal in Afrika, wo noch nichts steht, gibt es ja, und da ist auch GSM extrem populär, was muss man denn da als erstes ausrollen, um überhaupt eine Infrastruktur zu haben?
Das erste, was man ausrollen würde, sind die Basisstationen, die eigentlichen Antennen, die man auch sieht, wenn man mit dem Automat irgendwo auf der Autobahn rumfährt, und man schaut links und rechts, da sieht man dann teilweise diese Metallmasten, die 20 Meter hoch sind, und dann sind da oben drei.
Die mal so ein bisschen aussehen, wie so Bang und Olufsens Lautsprecher.
Genau, und da sind dann drei solche Schlangenteile drin, die die Antennen sind das, und die würde man als erstes in einem so einem Land ausstellen. Und GSM ist halt die Funkverbindung zu dieser Basisstation. GSM an sich, entwickelt in den 80er Jahren, also schon recht alt für Technologie. Und momentan über zwei Milliarden Benutzer auf GSM.
So eine Basisstation hat die jetzt, ist das jetzt wirklich nur eine Antenne, und dann ist da so ein Kabel dran, oder hat die auch eine eigene Intelligenz?
Die hat auch eine eigene Intelligenz. Diese Basisstation hat die physikalische Antenne, mit dem die Signale gesendet und empfangen werden. Und diese Signale werden dann in einen Switch reingeleitet, oder in eine Basisstation Concentrator, wo das dann ein bisschen ummoduliert wird, die Paketwerke ein wenig umstrukturiert und dann weiter gesendet zu einer Hauptstation im Netzwerk. Und diese Weiter-Sendung funktioniert normalerweise über normales Kabel, was entweder im Boden liegt oder über eine direkte Funkstrecke.
Das sind dann die Dinger, wo dann eben noch so eine Schüssel dran klebt. An Autobahnen sieht man das, glaube ich, häufiger.
Sieht aus wie so eine Satellitenschüssel, so ein rundes Ding, das ist dann eine direkte Funkverbindung oder auch über normale Landleitung.
Das heißt, man kann ein GSM-Netzwerk auch schon mit sehr wenig Kabeln über ein Land streuen. Das ist natürlich ein großer Vorteil. Gerade in Afrika, weil ein Kabel bleibt dann nicht lange im Boden. Hier übrigens mittlerweile auch nicht mehr so. Der Kupferpreis steigt. Okay, aber nur mit den Basisstationen alleine ist das jetzt nicht getan. Also da gibt es dann noch eine Hierarchie-Ebene da drüber.
Genau, der Mobiloperator, der dieses Netzwerk betreibt, der hat noch wesentlich mehr Infrastruktur als nur die Basisstation. Irgendwo müssen natürlich auch die Daten gespeichert werden von dem Teilnehmer. Und das wird in der AOC gespeichert, in der Authentication Database. Dort stehen dann die ganzen Geheimschlüssel, die sind dort vorhanden. Dort stehen die Identifikationen von den Teilnehmern drin und so weiter und so fort.
Das heißt, sowas gibt es für jeden Mobilfunkanbieter. Jeder Mobilfunkanbieter hat ein eigenes AOC, ein eigenes Authentication Center. Das ist im Prinzip seine Kundendaten.
Das ist seine Kundendaten.
Das heißt, da steht drin, Tim hat ein Handy und das hat die Telefonnummer sowieso.
Und Tim verwendet diesen geheimen Schlüssel. Und dies ist seine. Genau, das steht drin.
Und was für ein geheimer Schlüssel ist das jetzt?
Das ist ein Schlüssel, der sowohl beim Mobiloperator in der AOC vorhanden ist und der auch auf deiner SIM-Karte vorhanden ist. Wenn jetzt Tim ein Telefonat führen möchte, dann wird von diesem Schlüssel ein bestimmtes neues Key-Material erzeugt, um damit dann die Luftverbindung zu verschlüsseln.
Das heißt, ich habe in meiner SIM-Karte meinen eigenen Schlüssel und den habe nur ich.
Nein, auch dein Mobiloperator hat diesen Schlüssel.
Also symmetrisches Verschlüsselungsverfahren an der Stelle. Ihr beide. Aber eine andere SIM-Karte hat einen anderen Schlüssel.
Genau, jede SIM-Karte sollte einen anderen Schlüssel haben.
Das heißt, jeder Teilnehmer hat seine eigene Schlüssel und davon gibt es zwei Kopien. Einer hat der Teilnehmer, einer hat dieses AUC.
Genau.
Das heißt, wenn man irgendwie das AUC ist, dann hat man alle Schlüssel.
Dann hat man alle, ja. Das ist die Holy Grail, das AUC.
Okay, und sind die dann in so Bunkern untergebracht oder sind das so Lagerhallen irgendwo im Gewerbegebiet, wo man mal über einen Zaun springen kann?
Das weiß ich nicht. Ich weiß nichts über die physikalische Sicherheit dieser Infrastruktur.
Aber es gibt sicherlich eine.
Es hoffentlich gibt eine, aber sicherlich eine gibt es.
Wir hoffen das. Okay, das heißt, das war es schon. Ich brauche meine Base Stations und dann kommt schon das AOC, oder was?
Da kommt natürlich noch andere Datenbeis, wie zum Beispiel das HLR, wo dann drin steht, wo dieser Benutzer überhaupt ist, an welcher Basisstation ist er gerade angemeldet. Oder das VLA, wo dann drin steht, ob du in einem anderen Land bist, dann lockst du dich erst in das VLA ein. Was dann diese Anfrage weiterleitest?
Also das ist Home Location Register und Visitor Location Register. Also so eine temporäre Datenbank, wo dann steht, wo bin ich.
Genau, inzwischen welchen Basis-Stationen du dich gerade aufhältst. Und das weiß der Mobile-Arrater jederzeit, wo du dich aufhältst. Das muss er wissen, anders könnte er die Telefonate an dich weiterleiten.
Klar, ja das ist immer so lustig, wenn Leute so irgendwie, was, das Mobilfunknetz kann rausfinden, wo ich bin? Das habe ich schon ganz häufig gehört, woher wissen die denn, wo ich bin? Selbstverständlich, sonst würde das Telefon nicht klingeln. Wie sollte es sonst anders sein? Während man sich bewegt, wird quasi der Ort, und das ist dann quasi diese Zelle, also eine Base Station ist eine Zelle, richtig? Man redet ja immer so von Zellen, in denen man sich befindet, und es gibt große und es gibt kleine Zellen. In der Stadt sind sie ein bisschen kleiner.
Genau, die größte maximale Zelle in GSM hat ungefähr einen Radius von 30 km. Also ein Durchmesser von 60 km, was schon recht groß ist. Für Afrika ideal, für solche Städte wie Wien hier zum Beispiel. Da braucht man kleinere Zellen. Der Grund, warum man kleine Zellen braucht, ist, dass die maximale Anzahl von Teilnehmern, die zur gleichen Zeit ein Telefonat führen können, weniger als 1.000 ist.
Wodurch ist das beschränkt?
Das ist beschränkt durch die Frequenzbandbreite, auf der GSM operiert.
Da gibt es ja auch verschiedene.
Da gibt es verschiedene. Da gibt es drei oder vier große Bände.
Mit 900 fing es mal an.
Mit 900 gibt es 1.800 und 1.900. Wo man ist, werden verschiedene Frequenzbandbreite.
1.800, das waren ja die sogenannten E-Netze, als sie eingeführt wurden. Diese Unterscheidung hat man heute so nicht mehr. 1.900 ist, glaube ich, das in den USA gültige Band.
Das ist unterschiedlich. Das Ursprünglich war, dass man so, dass USA wurde, das zugewiesen, weil 1.800 war für was anderes reserviert. Aber mittlerweile wird auch da alles verwendet, genauso wie in Deutschland. Hier wird 900 verwendet und 1.800.
Aber wenn man heute so ein Handy kauft, dann steht ja meistens in den Specks drin ein Tri-Band-Handy. Und genau dort geht es, oder Quad-Band. Was ist denn das vierte Band?
Das Quad-Band würde dann alle Bänder unterstützen. Das sind 900 MHz, 1.800, 1.900 und 2.100 sogar.
Also damit hat man dann sozusagen für alle Bänder. Also es geht darum, weltweite Interoperabilität zu haben. Das war ja am Anfang auch nicht unbedingt so. Okay, das heißt, eigentlich braucht man nur so einen AOC, ein HLR, ein VLR. VLR ist halt für die Gäste, für das Roaming, wenn man sozusagen zu Gast ist im anderen Netz. Das heißt, das wird auch benutzt, wenn ich jetzt, keine Ahnung, ich bin im O2-Netz, bin aber auf dem Land, gibt es kein O2, benutze ich das Telekom-Netz mit, dann bin ich dann auch ein Gast, so als würde ich von Spanien kommen. Ja, und vielleicht, gut, jetzt haben wir das so von der Netzseite aufgerollt. Wie sieht denn das von der anderen Seite aus? Also was tut jetzt ein Telefon im GSM-Netz? Ich nehme jetzt mein Handy und es ist ausgeschaltet. Und dann schalte ich jetzt ein.
Gut.
Dann fragt er mich erstmal nach der PIN.
Genau, das erste, was das Mobiltelefon macht, das besteht aus zwei Sachen, das ist das Mobiltelefon und die SIM-Karte im Mobiltelefon. Das Mobiltelefon wird die SIM-Karte fragen oder der SIM-Karte sagen, ich habe mich eingeschaltet und würde dann der SIM-Karte sagen, fang doch mal an dich zu authentifizieren am Netzwerk. Dann wird die SIM-Karte entscheiden, auf welcher Frequenz der Mobiloperator ist. Wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel auf O2 hat, dann ist das O2 fest einprojumiert in der SIM-Karte, wo sich der Mobiloperator aufhält auf welcher Frequenz, das sogenannte Broadcast Channel. Und dort wird sich dann das Mobiltelefon versuchen einzuloggen.
Moment, aber es kommt ja noch einen Schritt vorher. Ich meine, wenn ich jetzt meine PIN eingebe, was schalte ich denn damit eigentlich frei? Also es gibt geheime Daten auf dieser Karte und man kann eben mit dieser Karte nur reden. Man kann sie nicht auslesen in dem Sinne.
Da hast du recht.
Man kommuniziert mit ihr.
Da hast du recht. Und genau das bewirkt deine PIN. Deine PIN schützt deine SIM-Karte lokal. Also die PIN wird nicht irgendwo übertragen und irgendwo hingesendet. Die wird nur an die SIM-Karte in dein Mobiltelefon gesendet, um der SIM-Karte zu sagen, dies ist der richtige User und fang jetzt an zu operieren. Das ist ein legitimierter User, der darf dich benutzen.
Und damit gibt es dann überhaupt erst Zugriff auf diesen Schlüssel, von dem wir vorhin schon gesprochen haben?
Auch da gibt es dann, nachdem man die PIN eingegeben hat, gibt es Zugriff auf die Algorithmen, die man dann verwenden kann, innerhalb der SIM-Karte. Selbst mit dem PIN kommt man nicht an den Schlüssel ran, aber man kann den Algorithmus verwenden, um Schlüsselmaterial zu erzeugen.
Das heißt, man erschließt sich mit der SIM-Karte so eine End- und Verschlüsselungsmaschine.
Genau.
So, und jetzt, wenn das also aufgeschlossen ist, dann geht es los mit dem Einbuchen. Jetzt muss das Telefon erstmal gucken, wo bin ich. So, das heißt, es macht die Antenne an und guckt mal, was macht das? Also wo guckt es denn nach? Das heißt, es klappert jetzt diese ganzen vier Bänder durch?
Das würde zu lange dauern. Das Telefon kennt die letzten paar Frequenzen, wo es erfolgreich einen Operator gefunden hat. Und es probiert erst die letzten paar Frequenzen durch. Und normalerweise finden sie immer den Operator auf der gleichen Frequenz. Das ist O2, wird man irgendwo auf 948 MHz finden oder irgend sowas. Das ist eine feste Frequenz.
Wie viele Frequenzen gibt es? Also pro Band?
Das Band pro Frequenz ist 200 KHz breit. Die Frequenz pro Channel ist 200 KHz breit. Und die Frequenzspektrum von einem Band ist normalerweise 25 MHz. Da kommen sie aus an 25.
25 MHz durch 20 KHz teilen. Da komme ich jetzt bestimmt mit den Nullen durcheinander. Also es sind einige. Ein Kanal heißt einfach, darüber wird dann telefoniert. Man sucht sich einen raus und probiert den, den er zuletzt gehabt hat.
Der erste Kanal, das ist der Beacon-Channel, das ist der Broadcast-Channel. Dort lockt sich jedes Mobiltelefon ein. Jedes Mobiltelefon lockt sich für seinen Operat auf den gleichen Broadcast-Channel ein. Und alle diese Mobiltelefone horchen auch auf diesen Broadcast-Channel für Nachrichten, die an alle gesendet werden.
Das heißt, das ist ein bisschen wie Ethernet?
Das ist ein bisschen wie Ethernet in der alten Zeit, wo es noch keine Switches gab, wo jeder alles mitlesen konnte.
Alle haben ihre Zimmer im gleichen Flur, machen die Tür auf und schreien rein oder horchen erstmal, was da erzählt wird.
Genau.
Beacon-Channel, also Funkfeuer, würde man auf Deutsch sagen. Das heißt, das ist so eine Art großes Hallo in den Netzwellen. Herrschte da Verschlüsselung schon in irgendeiner Form vor?
Nein, die Verschlüsselung gibt es nur während eines Telefonates oder während man eine SMS empfängt oder sendet.
Das heißt, alles andere, die ganze Signalisierung, wo bin ich, wo soll ich hin, grundsätzlich, wenn man das jetzt beleuchten wird wahrscheinlich Klartext sein und ist von daher auch mithörbar?
Natürlich.
So, und jetzt lausche ich als Telefon, ich bin ein Telefon, und ich lausche jetzt dem Funkfeuer. Was höre ich da? Also, die Netze melden sich oder was?
Das Erste, was die Mobilstation sagen wird, ist, wer bist du überhaupt? Und authentifiziere dich doch mal. Ich habe hier nämlich die AOC-Daten.
Aber wer spricht denn wen zuerst an?
Ich glaube, das Mobiltelefon spricht.
Muss ja eigentlich. Genau, muss ja erstmal sagen, mich gibt es. Das heißt, es lauscht erstmal nach den verfügbaren Netzen. Man muss ja auch meistens noch anwählen. Man kann auch sagen, hier buche dich ein.
Das macht das Mobiltelefon automatisch.
Ja gut, aber man kann ja auch diesen Modus aufrufen, wo man sagt, hier es gibt die und die Netze. Ich möchte jetzt aber genau da rein und dann nicht.
Genau, und diese Liste, die dir angezeigt wird, auf dein Mobiltelefon, wo du den Apparate auswählen kannst, da hat das Telefon schon alle Frequenzen abgesucht und hat auf diesen Frequenzen die Apparate gefunden und zeigt dir dann die Apparaturannahmen an.
Im Ausland ist das ja immer so ein Thema, weil da will man ja dann auch ein bestimmtes Netz, wo man jetzt nicht exorbitante Roaming-Gebühren zahlt, sondern nur komplett Verrückte. Andere gibt es ja derzeit leider noch nicht. Das heißt, das Telefon spricht die Basisstation an und sagt, hallo, ich bin es, dein Telefon. Lass mich rein. Ich bin...
Ja, das kommt der nächste Schritt. Dann sagt die Basisstation, wer bist du überhaupt? Authentifiziere dich auch mal. Und dann sagt das Telefon, ja, okay. Sende mir doch mal irgendeine Zufallszahl zu, die nennt sich Runt. Und diese Runt wird dann auch zugesendet von der Basisstation.
Auch im Klartext.
Auch im Klartext, ich nehm da alles mit. Das kommt alles noch, das ist alles auf dem Beacon-Channel, was hier passiert. Und dann nimmt das Mobiltelefon diese Runt und sendet ihr eine SIM-Karte. Und sagt der SIM-Karte, SIM-Karte, verwende doch mal den Geheimschlüssel und mach etwas mit der Runt und gib mir ein SRES, ein Result, ein Ergebnis zurück. SRES heißt das. Das ist ein Authentifizierungsergebnis. Das kann nur erzeugt werden, wenn man diesen geheimen Schlüssel hat. Den du als SIM-Teil nehmt, auf deiner SIM hast du den. Und natürlich der Mobile-Operator hat den. Dein Mobiltelefon sendet dann diese SRES zurück an die Basisstation. Und die Basisstation gleicht das mit der SRES ab, die die Basisstation von der AOC empfangen hat.
Das heißt, diese Zufallszahl wird eigentlich an zwei Stellen gesendet. Einerseits an dieses Authentication Center. So nach dem Motto, sag mir doch mal, was das Telefon jetzt sagen müsste. Und das Telefon muss es dann halt sagen. Und wenn die Zahlen dann stimmen, dann ist das dann authentifiziert.
So ungefähr. Im Detail sogar ist es die Authentizierungsdatenbank, die random und die SRES an die Basisstation sendet.
Das heißt, die Basisstation bedient sich an der Stelle schon dieses Zentrums. Ach, der Motto, sag mir doch mal, was ich dem sagen muss. Und was ist das jetzt für eine Verschlüsselung an dieser Stelle, die dort greift? Ist das dieser Sagenumwobene A5-Algorithmus?
Nein, der Authentizierungsalgorithmus ist der A3 oder der Key-Generation-Algorithmus A8. Das ist ein anderer Algorithmus. Der A5-Algorithmus wird dann später verwendet, um die eigentlichen Contentdaten zu verschlüsseln. Das heißt, das, was wir sprechen und die Textnachricht, die wir versenden.
Aber das basiert alles auf demselben Schlüssel?
Nein, es basiert alles auf den ursprünglichen Schlüssel, den du kennst und den der Mobile-Apparater kennt. A8 wird dann verwendet, um daraus einen neuen Schlüssel für A5 zu generieren. Aber ursprünglich kommt alles von diesem geheimen Schlüssel und der Random Value, dieser Zufallszahl.
Jetzt bin ich da und sehe mehrere Basis-Stationen.
Genau, dein Mobiltelefon wird immer die stärkste Basis-Station auswählen. Idealerweise sollte das Mobiltelefon zur gleichen Zeit sechs Basis-Stationen kennen. Das wäre ein Idealzustand. Es misst kontinuierlich die Signalstärke von all diesen sechs Basis-Stationen.
Warum ist das jetzt so ideal?
Weil es dann die maximale Möglichkeit hat, die beste Auswahl zu treffen. Es kann dann immer zur stärksten hingehen. Und wenn die stärkste ausfällt, kannst du zur zweitstärksten hingehen.
Kannst du das nicht auch mit fünf?
Ja, kann ich schon. Aber die maximale Anzahl ist sechs. Es wird nie mehr als sechs.
Umso mehr, umso besser sozusagen. Aber mehr als sechs würde es sich gar nicht auseinandersetzen. Und wissen dann diese Basis-Stationen auch voneinander, dass sie alle dasselbe Telefon sehen? Also wie funktioniert dann dieses Roaming, bzw. dieses Handover an der Stelle?
Genau, das wird Handover genannt.
Also ich fahre auf der Autobahn, bin in Zelle X eingebucht, und ich nähere mich mit 200 Stundenkilometern in Zelle Y. Und irgendwann ist dann die andere stärker. Dann entscheidet mein Telefon. Ich möchte jetzt zu der, weil die ist irgendwie cooler.
Genau, das stimmt. Die Entscheidung wird auf dem Telefon gemacht. Die Entscheidung wird nicht von der Basis-Station gemacht. Das heißt, das Telefon irgendwann sagt, hey, die neue Basis-Station ist viel stärker, und ich sende jetzt alle Daten einfach über die. Und das war es eigentlich schon. Da wird keine Autonisierung mehr gemacht, weil du bist ja schon authentifiziert.
Aber woher weiß das die andere?
Die Basis-Station kommuniziert über das zentrale Netzwerk des Mobiloperators und fragt an, ob dieser Teilnehmer authentifiziert ist.
Ah, okay, gut. Das heißt, das gilt dann immer für eine Weile, bis man dann irgendwie nicht mehr lang genug gesehen wird, und dann wird man ausgebucht, und wenn man dann angerufen wird, dann ist dieser Teilnehmer vorbeigehen, nicht zu erreichen. Gut, das heißt, ab dem Moment, wo ich mich authentifiziere, dann bin ich eingebucht. Manche Telefone sagen dann ja auch, welche Zelle man hat. Es gibt ja dann so einen Monitor-Modus.
Genau, da gibt es den berühmten Nokia-Monitor-Modus, den Field-Test-Software von Nokia, was man auch im Internet runterladen kann, und was auf vielen üblichen Nokia-Telefonen läuft.
Schon freigeschaltet ist, oder?
Ja, absolut.
Also schon drin ist, ohne dass man sich das runterladen muss, oder? Ist ja sowieso schon drin bei einigen Telefonen?
Bei manchen Telefonen ist es schon drin. Beim iPhone ist es zum Beispiel schon drin, der Netzwerk-Monitor. Und für die Nokia-Fone muss man sich das runterladen. Das läuft zum Beispiel auf den Nokia 6630, Nokia 6680, Nokia N72 und so weiter.
Und dann sieht man diese ganzen Daten, also dann kriegt man angezeigt, was das Telefon so sieht. Welche Basestations gibt es, wie heißen die, was sind die für Signalstärke und so weiter.
All diese Informationen sind dort verfügbar.
Also wenn man irgendwie Langeweile hat, anstatt dass man die ganze Zeit Breakout spielt, kann man sich dann auch irgendwie die Basestationsdaten anschauen. So, und wenn ich jetzt, also jetzt bin ich im Prinzip anrufbar. Sprich, wenn mich jetzt jemand anruft, dann schnackt einfach die Basestation mit mir. Und geht das dann alles immer noch über diesen Funkfeuerkanal? Ist das immer noch dieser Beacon-Channel?
Das erste Rufen geht über den Funkfeuerkanal. Die Basestation wird dann irgendwann sagen, hallo, ich möchte gerne mit dem Mobiltelefon so und so reden, weil da irgendwas passiert. Sie sagt nicht genau was, aber irgendwas passiert. Dann meldet sich das Mobiltelefon. Alle horchen ja auf dem Beacon-Channel. Sagt dann das gerufene Mobiltelefon, na, das bin ich ja. Ich meld mich mal und sage der Base Station, ja, was ist denn los, was hast du denn für mich? Dann sagt die Base Station, ja, ich möchte mit dir auf einem dedicated Channel, auf einem eigenen Kanal mich mit dir unterhalten. Und geh doch mal auf diesen eigenen Kanal. Dann wird dieser Mobiltelefon mitgeteilt, auf welchen Kanal es gehen soll. Und wie dann die Hopping-Frequenz usw. aussieht. Und das Mobiltelefon wechselt dann auf diesen Kanal. Auf diesem Kanal geht es dann weiter. Und es wird noch mal authentifiziert, um sicherzugehen, dass der Mobiltelefon auch wirklich der Mobiltelefon ist. Das Ganze random hingesetzt, S-Rest zurück, da. Und irgendwann wird dann entschieden, jetzt fangen wir an, das zu verströssen.
Das ist schon mal einer der Gründe, warum überhaupt so ein Verbindungsaufbau auch so lange dauert.
Das wäre eine der Gründe, ja.
Wie bei ISDN, das da immer so ein bisschen so hin und her. Und dann wird endlich verschlüsselt. Das heißt, Verschlüsselung in GSM bezieht sich eigentlich nur auf das Audio, was hin und her geht.
Auf den Dedicated Channel. Nun war es im Dedicated Channel hauptsächlich.
Also der gesamte Kanal, der da so... Die Base Station sagt dem Telefon, bitte ab jetzt in diesem Kanal. Und alles, was dann in diesem Kanal läuft, ist mit diesem A5A-Gruppe verschlüsselt.
Genau, nach dem Austausch des Ski-Materials und der Audiosierung ist dann in diesem Kanal alles verschlüsselt. Und das ist dann, was in dem Kanal gemacht wird, ist entweder Voice Traffic, Textnachrichten, SMS oder alte Modem-Traffic, wenn das noch jemand verwendet. Und die ist dann verschlüsselt.
Aber alles ist verschlüsselt, auch die SMS. Auf dem Weg bis zur Basestation. Aber auch nur bis dahin.
Genau, nur die Luftschnittstelle in GSM ist verschlüsselt.
Das heißt, in dem Moment, wo das so eine Basestation ist, wo so eine Richtfunkantenne dran klebt, so eine Satellitenschüssel, dann kann es sehr gut sein, dass ab da schon wieder alles unverschlüsselt ist.
Das kann nicht nur sein, das ist garantiert so. Die Basestation entschlüsselt und sendet die Daten in Klartext weiter.
Diese Richtfunkstrecken sind nicht verschlüsselt?
Ja, das weiß ich nicht, aber die Basestation an sich entschlüsselt ist. Ob das dann wieder verschlüsselt wird auf einer bestimmten Richtfunkstrecke, ich bezweifle, das wird garantiert nicht verschlüsselt, wenn es über das Kupferkabel geht oder ein Glasfaserkabel. Das ist garantiert Klartext.
Aber gerade bei Richtfunkstrecken ist das natürlich so eine Sache, weil dann brauchen wir sie ja nicht nur neben die Autobahn stellen und Antenne hochhalten.
Das ist wohl wahr.
Okay, ihr merkt schon, liebe Hörer, jetzt wird es langsam spannend. Das heißt, die Anrufe werden zum Telefon geleitet. Das Telefon entscheidet selber, mit welcher Base Station es redet. Und in dem Moment, wo irgendwas Wichtiges passiert, wie ein Telefonanruf oder SMS, oder was war das dritte Beispiel? Modem, Datenkommunikation. Dann ist das alles verschlüsselt. Aber eben nur bis zu dieser Bang & Olufsen-Lautsprecherbox, die da irgendwo auf einem Baum montiert ist. Du hast so ein schönes Foto gezeigt, bei deinem Vortrag von so einer getarnten Mobilzelle. Wo war das?
Das war in Großbritannien. Die Leute haben sich dort langsam beschwert, dass sie nicht diese Metallforsten in ihren Vordergärten stehen haben wollen. Und der Mobiloperator hat dann angefangen, solche Antennen zu bauen, die aussehen wie Bäume.
Das heißt, das ist ein Tannebaum.
Der 100% gerade ist und sich im Wind auch nicht bewegt.
Der aber auch oben einen extra Kraft hat. Der sah sehr putzig aus, aber definitiv nicht so sehr auf. Wenn es die Leute glücklich macht. Das war's jetzt eigentlich, oder? Jetzt sind wir einmal durch die GSM-Geschichte durchgelaufen. Jetzt hattest du in dem Vortrag erwähnt, dass diese A5-Verschlüsselung ein wackeliger Kandidat ist. Was ist denn so der Kenntnisstand? Das ist ja eigentlich ein geheimer Algorithmus. Der ist nicht publiziert worden.
Genau.
Das steht also nicht in einem GSM-Standard, den man sich für 100 Dollar schicken kann. Das dürfen nur Leute wissen, die in irgendwelchen Gremien sitzen und böse Zettel unterschrieben haben.
Genau, so wurde es ursprünglich entwickelt. Geheim, es wurde nie verifiziert, wie sicher es überhaupt ist. Irgendein halbschlauer Mensch hat gesagt, das ist sicher. Er hat seine Unterschrift drunter gesetzt. Dann wurde er bekannt, dann wurde herausgefunden, er ist doch nicht so sicher, wie der eine Typ dachte. Das ist das Problem, wenn man Kryptographie in einer geschlossenen Community macht und das nicht vorher verifizieren lässt von anderen Leuten. Das dann irgendwann zerbricht und zerbrochen ist es in 1998 bereits. Und zwar haben da Leute wie Shamir, Wagner, Birkhoff und andere Leute diesen Algorithmus auseinandergenommen und die ersten Schwachstellen gefunden. Seitdem Datum war klar, A5 ist nicht sicher. Was die Leute damals gemacht haben, war, dass sie akademische Angriffe gefunden haben. Also Angriffe, die immer noch 90 Sekunden Mitschnitt der Daten brauchten oder die immer noch mehrere Tage benötigt haben, um die GSM-Konvention zu entschlüsseln. Und wir haben uns halt vorgenommen, das ist nicht praktisch. Praktisch 90% aller Telefonate sind kürzer als 90 Sekunden. SMS sind nur ein paar Millisekunden lang. Und wir würden doch auch gerne mal versuchen, das zu entschlüsseln. Und wie machen wir denn das?
Schön gesagt, das ist nicht praktisch. Aber es gibt ja bereits Abhörsysteme. Ich glaube, der Trick ist, dass man halt einfach so tut, als wäre man selber eine Base Station. Also, spüren wir mal vor, es gibt natürlich einen großen Markt für Geheimdienste, die, wenn sie jetzt rein zufällig mal nicht direkt den Zugriff auf das GSM-Netzwerk selber haben, wie das heutzutage in jeder halbwegs fortschrittlichen Diktatur sicherlich sein wird, man sozusagen wirklich darauf angewiesen ist, das Telefon direkt am Telefon abzugreifen. Da gibt es diese schönen Geräte mit dem tollen Namen IMSI-Catcher.
Ja, genau. Also schön, dass du es auch erwähnt hast, dass an sich kann jeder, der Zugriff auf die Basisstation hat, sowieso schon jedes Gespräch abhören. Weil dort ist es ja Klartext. Das heißt, wenn irgendein Geheimdienst, ein Telefonat, wenn irgendjemand abhören möchte, gehen die einfach nur zum Mobile-Apparate und sagen, wir möchten gerne von dieser Person die Daten haben und den jetzt abhören.
Da wird ein Kabel reingesteckt?
Da wird ein Kabel reingesteckt, da gibt es spezielle Software, die man sich auf seinen Windows-PC installiert. Dann kommt ein ganz normales Netzkabel rein und dann sieht man alle Leute und alle Daten. Dann kommt es dir einen schönen Ruckkopf vor.
Genau dieselbe Situation wie im Festnetz.
Genau.
Oh mein GSM-Telefon, das hat ja auch Verschlüsselung. Da ist auch mal ein Schloss in meinem Bildschirm. Das ist eigentlich Augenwischerei. Das ist Hokus Pokus, ja. Aber wenn man jetzt nicht ohne Weiteres reinmarschieren kann, also wenn man, sagen wir mal, nicht den passenden Richterbeschluss hat, zum Beispiel sollte da noch jemand drauf Wert legen, dann gibt es auch Geräte, die eine Basestation simulieren.
Genau, das sind die heute üblichen verwendeten Methoden, um GSM abzufangen. Und zwar sind sie sogenannten IMSI-Catcher, rot und schwarz hat da viel Publik mitgemacht.
Die Geräte haben wir noch nicht erklärt, ne?
IMSI ist die International Mobile Subscription Identification. Das ist eine lange Nummer, die ein Teilnehmer identifiziert.
Das ist aber nicht mal eine Telefonnummer?
Das ist nicht deine Telefonnummer. Die Telefonnummer wird dir vom Mobiloperator zugewiesen.
Das heißt, das ist sozusagen die ID meiner SIM-Karte?
Das ist die ID deiner SIM-Karte, die sich auch nie wechselt. Du kannst zum Beispiel deine Telefonnummer wechseln, aber deine IMSI wird sich niemals wechseln, die ist immer gleich.
Es sei denn, ich kriege eine neue SIM-Karte?
Natürlich, wenn du eine neue SIM-Karte bekommst, dann ändert sich auch die IMSI. Die IMSI ist auf deiner SIM-Karte gespeichert.
Okay, aber man kann ja immerhin sagen, meine SIM-Karte ist im Eimer, habe ich verloren, was auch immer. Da kriegt man eine neue zugeschickt, zumindest schon mal eine Möglichkeit, wie man da seinen Fingerabdruck ein bisschen verwischen kann. Und was macht jetzt dieser IMSI-Catcher genau?
Dieser IMSI-Catcher simuliert eine Basisstation. Und zwar ist es eine kleine Basisstation mit einem sehr starken Signal. Die sagt einfach jedem Teilnehmer, ich bin jetzt die stärkste Basisstation, dem stärksten Signal. Und alle Teilnehmer in deren Umgebung erkennen diese Basisstation und sagen, hoho, da ist eine stärkere Basisstation, ich lock mich doch bei der ein.
Aber gibt es denn keine Authentifizierung? Es ist schön zu sehen, dass das Telefon sich gegenüber dem Netzwerk authentifizieren muss. Es gibt aber keinerlei Mechanismus, dass sich das Netzwerk dem Telefon gegenüber authentifizieren muss.
Das ist richtig, es ist eine einseitige Authentifizierung. Das Mobiltelefon kann nicht feststellen, ob die Basisstation, mit der es kommuniziert, eine legitimierte Basisstation vom richtigen Mobile-Operator ist, oder ob es ein IMSI-Catcher ist von irgendeinem Geheimdienst. Das kann man nicht feststellen.
Also ungefähr so, als ob ich irgendwie meine eigene WLAN-Basestation mit zu Starbucks nehme und dann ein Netz aufmache, das heißt dann T-Com-Hotspot. Und dann kommen die Leute und sagen, oh, ein T-Com-Hotspot und loggen sich da ein. Und wenn ich dann irgendwie sage, ja hier, gib mal Passwort her, dann ist schon Big Trouble, so die Richtung.
Genau. Oder wenn du dich mit einem Bankangestellten unterhältst, du denkst, er ist von Citibank. Er kennt dich, aber du kennst ihn nicht. Und er fragt dich nach all deinen Details.
Oder eine Webseite im bösen World Wide Web was behauptet, hallo, ich bin deine Bank, logg dich mal ein. Also im Prinzip reden wir hier von Fishing. Ein IMSI-Catcher ist so eine Art GSM-Fishing.
Ja, so kann man es auch nennen. Die täuscht einem vor, dass sie die richtige Basisstätzung ist.
Aber merkt man das denn nicht auch? Also hat man nicht irgendeine Chance, das zu bemerken?
Ja, es gibt natürlich Möglichkeiten, das zu merken.
Also er kann ja nicht mit mir verschlüsselt kommunizieren, weil er hat ja nicht mal einen Schlüssel.
Ja, selbst da gibt es Tricks. Selbst mit der Verschlüsselung gibt es jetzt schon. Die letzten Systeme täuschen ja auch die Verschlüsselung vor. Ja, das bin ich auch noch daran herauszufinden, wie das genau geht.
Aber du meinst mit Vortäuschen, dass das Telefon ein Symbol anzeigt, dass es verschlüsselt sei, obwohl es das nicht ist.
Es wird dann sogar richtig verschlüsselt.
Also wir müssen das glaube ich auch noch mal klar machen. Also diese Verschlüsselung, von der wir geredet haben, die ist optional. Wenn die Base Station nicht sagt, bitte ab jetzt verschlüsseln, dann tut es das Telefon nicht.
Genau, die Base Station sagt dem Mobiltelefon, diese sind die drei Algorithmen, die ich supporte. Der erste Algorithmus ist kein Algorithmus. Der zweite Algorithmus ist A5-slash-1. Und der dritte Algorithmus ist eine schwere Variante von A5-slash-1. Das ist A5-slash-2 dann. Und die Base Station kann natürlich sagen, die einzigen Algorithmen, die ich supporte, ist kein Algorithmus. Und das Mobiltelefon...
Und dann sagt das Telefon so, oh den kann ich.
Ja genau, das kann ich garantiert und das mache ich doch. Für mich hat gar nichts.
Und dann ist sozusagen die Kommunikation... Aber das zeigt das Telefon dann in der Regel an?
Die meisten Telefone zeigen das nicht mal an. Ursprünglich war das mal so, dass die Telefone das anzeigen mit einem kleinen Schloss, wenn man wählt. Die Hersteller der Mobiltelefone wurden aber gebeten, dieses Schloss nicht mehr anzuzeigen.
Ach, von wem? Graue Eminenzen mit Trenchcodes. Wir wissen es nicht, wir können nur drüber philosophieren. Mit anderen Worten, liebe Leute, eure Telefone mögen euch sagen, was haben sie gesagt, dass immer das Schloss angezeigt werden soll, oder es soll nie angezeigt werden? Dass man gar nicht auf die Idee kommt, es könnte mal so, mal so sein. Sondern du telefonierst, alles ist in Ordnung, sei beruhigt, bitte weitergehen, es gibt nichts zu sehen.
Verstehe.
Was kostet so ein IMSI-Catcher, wenn ich jetzt mal so ein bisschen telefonieren möchte?
Mehrere 10.000 Euro. Das sind nicht die billigsten Dinge.
Aber das fällt einem doch eigentlich sofort auf, wenn so ein IMSI-Catcher ist, weil der ist ja nicht Teil des Netzes, oder bucht der sich dann hintenrum wieder in das Netz ein?
Der bucht sich hintenrum wieder ins Netz ein und leitet das alles schön weiter. Das ist fast eine transparente Attacke.
Das heißt, der tut gegenüber dem Netz so, als wäre ich ich, kriegt auch von mir eigentlich alle Daten. Also er kann auch diese Authentifizierung durchschleichen. Das heißt, eigentlich ist das eine richtige Man-in-the-middle-Attacke, wie man sagt. Und zwar im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes. So ein kleiner VW-Kleinbus, so schwarz, wahrscheinlich mit getönten Scheiben.
Unauffällig.
Unauffällig, steht irgendwo an der Straßenecke. Mein Telefon bucht sich in diesem Bus ein, in dem Glauben, es wäre jetzt irgendwie ein Netzwerk, was es nicht ist. Aber ich kann trotzdem telefonieren, weil er sich wiederum für mich im richtigen Netzwerk einbucht. Bloß mit dem Trick, dass die Datenverschlüsselung auf dem Weg zum Bus ausgeschaltet ist.
Genau.
Und da können Sie alle schön mithören.
Genau so funktioniert es.
Toll. Na, dann ist doch alles gut, oder? Das ist ja sehr beunruhigend. Aber ihr habt ja noch ein paar mehr beunruhigende Sachen gefunden. Jetzt hast du ja schon gesagt, dieser Verschlüsselungsalgorithmus ist an sich mathematisch schon angegriffen worden von den historischen Auguren der Kryptographie. Also, die haben nach dem... Wie sind die denn überhaupt auf diesen Algorithmus gekommen?
Das hat jemand reverse-engineert von einer SIM-Karte. Da hat also jemand sich die SIM-Karte genommen, hat die mal unter das Elektronenmikroskop gelegt und hat dann doch tatsächlich mal sich den Algorithmus darunter geladen und sich dann angeschaut, wie der funktioniert. Revers-engineert.
Das ist auch immer so ein interessanter Glaube. Das sehe ich auch mal häufig bei großen Technologie-Companies oder auch bei Regierungen und so. Nach dem Motto, das ist ja alles geheim, es bleibt ja auch geheim, weil es ist ja im Chip und da kann ja keiner reingucken, was Quatsch ist. Was kostet denn so ein Elektronenraster-Mikroskop heutzutage?
In der Hinsicht auf SIM war es ja kompletter Quatsch und jeder, der Student war, kommt wahrscheinlich an seinen Elektronen-Mikroskop umarant.
Ach so, steht er in den Unis irgendwie schon rum?
Ja, natürlich. Muss man den nicht kaufen.
Aber wenn man es kauft, bringt es einen auch nicht gleich um? Nee, kann man natürlich auch kaufen. Das heißt, er hat sich wirklich jetzt die Funktionsweise des Chips angeschaut und daraufhin einen Algorithmus zurückentwickelt.
Und die dann verglichen mit Testvektoren, die es freigekommt.
Und darauf konnte er dann auch sicher sagen, ok, jetzt habe ich es auch genau gefunden, weil ich jetzt für die gleichen Eingaben gleiche Ergebnisse bekomme. Und daraufhin kamen dann die Mathematiker, die Kryptographen und haben gesagt, das ist alles scheiße und das stinkt. Jetzt hast du gesagt, das ist aber jetzt nicht, da sind wir ja zu den IMSI-Catchern eben abgebogen, das wäre ja jetzt alles nicht so Realtime. Also für den sportlichen Überwacher von heute reicht es eigentlich nicht. Also einerseits ist die Sache mit dem Bus ein bisschen aufwendig, weil man braucht ja immer einen Bus. Ja, man muss ja so rumfahren.
Schwarzer Bus vor allen Dingen.
Und können Netze eigentlich, wenn sie wollten, diese IMSI-Catcher irgendwie erkennen eigentlich?
Also mit der existierenden Technologie, die an den Basisstationen verfügbar ist, können sie die IMSI-Catcher nicht erkennen. Aber mit spezieller Technologie könnte man nach diesen IMSI-Catchern fahrenden. Aber es ist wahrscheinlich die gleichen Leute, die danach fahrenden, die sie auch verwenden.
Okay, da wird dann einfach mal drüber hinweggeschaut. Gut, aber was habt ihr denn jetzt noch gestartet? Also ihr habt ja ein Projekt, das heißt GSM Software Project.
Genau.
Da gibt es ein schönes Wiki dazu. Und da gibt es wiki.thc.org.gsm, wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung habe. Kannst du mal sagen, was das jetzt da ist und was euer Projektziel ist?
Es gibt zwei Sachen, was wir machen. Die erste Sache ist, wir möchten GSM-Signale empfangen und verarbeiten können. Und wir möchten auch eine neue Attacke herausbringen, um diese GSM-Verschlüsselung zu knacken. Das sind zwei Sachen. Und die erste Sache verwenden wir das USRP. Das ist ein Gerät, was von MatEtus entwickelt worden ist. Für 900 US-Dollar kann man das kaufen. Das kann einfach alles empfangen. Das empfängt alles von 0 bis 5 Gigahertz.
Das ist eher ein universeller Frequenz-Auseinander-Fummler. Das ist eine Box, da läuft GNU Radio drin, wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Das ist praktisch ein Empfänger. Der kann alles empfangen. Der kann normales Radio empfangen. Der kann auch GPS empfangen oder selbst Fernsehen empfangen. Natürlich kann er auch GSM empfangen, wenn er richtig eingestellt wird.
Also sofern das Gerät nur die passenden Antennen angeschlossen bekommt.
Passende Antennen angeschlossen und passende Software drauf. Dann kann er das alles empfangen.
Was kostet so ein Teil? 900 US-Dollar. Ich sehe hier gerade, da sitzen sogar nur 700 US-Dollar. Oder fehlt da noch irgendwas dabei?
Ja, da kommen noch Antennen dazu. Wir haben damals einen speziellen Preis von Matt Etos bekommen. Wir haben 10% Rabatt bekommen für unser Projekt.
Aber so viel ist das ja noch nicht für einen Universal-Empfänger. Leute, wir geben das für ihr Küchenradio aus. Zumindest für ihre Bang und Olufsen-Anlage.
Die Software gibt es natürlich kostenlos auf dem Internet. Das ist ein ganzes Projekt, was Leute mit dem USAP schon gemacht haben. Unter anderem fangen die wirklich Fernsehen damit oder normales Radio oder GPS.
Es ist vielleicht noch mal wert, das zu betonen. Also GNU Radio ist wirklich ein schon lange existierendes Projekt, ganz hervorragendes Software, die das macht, worum es geht. Radio, es geht einfach um Wellenempfang. Das ist sozusagen ein universeller Source Code, den man einfach zum Dekodieren, aber auch zum Enkodieren von allem möglich machen. Das heißt, man kann damit ein Radio bauen, also etwas, was wirklich Radiowellen aussendet. Man kann einen Radioempfänger damit bauen. Genauso kann man Sender und Empfänger auch für alle anderen Sachen bauen. Durch den GSM-Fall heißt das im Prinzip, dass man jetzt auf diese Bänder geht, von denen wir vorhin schon gesprochen haben, 800 MHz, 900 MHz und so weiter. Das heißt, man lauscht eigentlich mit dieser Box genauso in den Himmel, wie das ein Telefon auch tut. Und was gibt es da jetzt so für Software? Also was kann diese Software? Also gibt es schon eine Software für dieses USRP, die das macht?
Die Basissoftware ist das GNU-Radio-Projekt. Und das kommt mit einem bestimmten Satz von Software, mit dem man das USRP ansprechen kann. Was Leute aus unserer Gruppe entwickelt haben, ist die Demodulation für GSM, speziell für GSM. Sodass man die GSM-Signale wirklich in lesbare Signale umwandeln kann.
Das heißt, man hat so einen Software-Layer. Wenn man da mit eigener Software rangeht, dann spricht man so direkt die Datenpakete, wie sie eigentlich definiert sind für GSM.
Genau.
Man entschlüsselt sozusagen das ganze Frequenzwirrwarr und hat eine digitale Schnittstelle, als wäre man direkt mit Ethernet verbunden.
Man kriegt dann schöne Pakete, jedes 23 Bytes lang. Das sind dann die richtigen GSM-Pakete, wie sie gesendet werden.
Und das GSM, ist es ein komplexes Protokoll?
Sehr komplex. Entwickelt in den 80er Jahren, ursprünglich an der Weiterung von ISDN. Es hat sehr viel Ähnlichkeit zu ISDN. Es ist ein unheimlich komplexes Protokoll, verteilt über Trillionen von Standards, für die man teilweise zahlen muss, teilweise auch kostenlos verfügbar sind. Und aus diesen Wirrwarr muss man dann sich raussuchen, was es wirklich bedeutet, was man da anfängt.
Aber nicht alles ist implementiert. Habt ihr jetzt nur einen Teil implementiert?
Der Teil, der uns interessiert hat, ist implementiert. Wir haben einen großen Teil von der Funktionalität eines Mobiltelefons implementiert. Besonders der ganze Beacon-Channel ist implementiert, dass man nahezu jede Nachricht vom Beacon-Channel dekodieren kann.
Aber es geht nicht nur ums Dekodieren, sondern auch ums selber sprechen. Es ist richtig bidirektional. Man kann auch antworten.
In der Theorie, das USAP könnte auch antworten, wir können noch nicht antworten. Wir können noch nicht mit dem USAP senden. Momentan empfangen wir nur.
Weil jetzt der Teil des Protokolls noch nicht geschrieben ist? Oder weil da jetzt so antennentechnisch irgendwas fehlt?
Weil der Teil der Software noch nicht geschrieben worden ist.
Aber im Prinzip ist es vorstellbar, dass es dann auch irgendwann dahin kommt, dass man auf diesem USAP-Gerät, so eine Box, dass das Ding einfach nur in Software alles tut, was ein GSM-Mobiltelefon mit den eingebauten, und das muss man dazu sagen, lizenzierten und offiziell zugelassenen Chips tut.
Das ist richtig, ja.
Ohne Einschränkungen. Das heißt, man könnte sich so sein eigenes Telefon machen.
Sein eigenes Telefon machen oder auf seine eigene Basisstation aufsetzen.
Wie klobig ist denn dieses USAP? Wie groß ist denn dieses Gerät?
Das USAP ist 10 mal 20 Zentimeter ungefähr.
Das ist ein recht kleines Gerät.
Kleiner als dein Laptop.
Okay, also schon so ein bisschen wie das gute alte Pocky-Zähnetz-Telefon so in der Größenordnung. Vielleicht nicht dieselbe Form, aber so von der Masse her? Okay, das ist ja auch schön retro. Noch eine dicke Antenne dran. Dann läuft man wieder mit so einer Lit-Fastholde durch die Gegend. Also gut, ihr habt jetzt sozusagen die Sendeseite. Das heißt, ihr könnt auf jeden Fall schon mal zuhören. Jetzt haben wir ja vorhin schon ganz gut ausgebreitet, was dieses Telefon-Alli auf dem Netzwerk tut. Das heißt, man kann jetzt einfach seine Antenne in die Luft halten und man kriegt vollständig dekodiert die gesamte Kommunikation zwischen dem Telefon und den Basis-Stationen.
Vom Beacon-Channel, ja.
Von diesem Beacon-Channel, von diesem Funkfeuer, in dem nichts verschlüsselt ist.
Genau.
Das heißt, man kriegt mit, dass da ein Telefon mit einer Basestation redet und zurück. Man kriegt mit, dass die Basestation dem Telefon sagt, dass irgendwas Tolles ist und sich jetzt einen neuen Kanal aufmachen möchte. Anruf, SMS, Datenkommunikation.
Dass das Mobiltelefon eingeschaltet worden ist, dass ein anderes Mobiltelefon gerade in diese Basis-Station sich einloggt oder zu einer anderen Basis-Station überwechselt. All diese Informationen sind unverschließlich.
Und man kriegt auch diese ganzen Austausch mit Random Numbers.
Genau, die Random Numbers.
Und die Ergebnisse davon. Und das heißt, wenn man jetzt die Schwächen dieser A5-Verschlüsselung nimmt, dann könnte man im Prinzip auch diese ganze Authentifizierung simulieren?
Genau. Wenn man jetzt sich sein eigenes USAP baut und damit dann auch senden kann und man schließt dazu eine SIM-Karte an, dann kann man das wirklich als Mobiltelefon verwenden. Dann kann man sich komplett autentifizieren mit dem USAP ins Netzwerk rein.
Aber man könnte dann, wenn man sozusagen jetzt die Schwachstellen dieses Protokolls nimmt, die du ja schon beschrieben hast, im Prinzip, also reichen diese Daten, die da hin und her gehen, um herauszufinden, was da für einen Schlüssel verwendet wird?
Teilweise. Da kommen wir jetzt in den Bereich, wo wir, unser zweites Projekt, wo wir A5 versuchen zu knacken. Jetzt will ich noch einmal den Unterschied erklären, was die Akademiker 98 gemacht haben, war den Algorithmus an sich analysiert. Sie haben eine passive Attacke gefunden, die, ich glaube, das Beste, was sie herausgefunden haben, ist 90 Sekunden. Klar, GSM-Traffic müssen sie mitschneiden und erst dann können sie es knacken. Vergleich zum IMSI-Catchern. Der IMSI-Catcher ist eine aktive Attacke. Das heißt, da wird eine Basisstation simuliert, die sendet auch Daten, die zerstört auch ein bisschen das Mobilnetzwerk, wo man sich aufhält. Die hat auch nur eine Reichweite von 100 oder 200 Metern. Und die können dann auch mit sniffen und die Daten in Klartext abfangen.
Aber da muss man schon irgendwie den Leuten auch auf der Spur sein.
Da muss man den Leuten auf der Spur sein, mit dem schwarzen Auto hinterherfahren, 100 bis 200 Meter maximal und das war's dann. Was wir jetzt machen, ist, das wollen wir nicht. Wir wollen einfach zu Hause auf unserer Couch sitzen und die Luxus-Variante komplett passiv, ohne etwas zu senden, passives Mitlauschen GSM zu entschlüsseln. Das ist das Ziel.
Und das heißt, man kann auch nichts ausprobieren, sondern man muss eigentlich nur die ganze Zeit mitlauschen, analysieren. Jetzt sind ja Telefongespräche nicht besonders lang. Das heißt, es muss sehr schnell gehen. Oder man schneidet alles mit und rechnet dann später da darüber.
Genau so machen wir das. Man schneidet alles mit und dann kann man sich später aussuchen, welchen Mobilteilnehmer man jetzt entschlüsse möchte. Und die Entschlüssung dauert momentan eine Stunde. Man braucht dafür noch eine spezielle Hardware, einen FPGA. Das ist so ein ganz schneller Prozessor, der für 600 US-Dollar verfügbar ist. Und zwei ganz große Festplatten. Diese Daten, die man für die Festplatten braucht, die werden wir verfügbar stellen.
Und ihr habt auch dieses Design gemacht für dieses FPGA.
Genau, wir haben das Design für das FPGA gemacht. Oder wir haben den Algorithmus dafür geschrieben, den Code, der darauf ausgeführt wird. Und wir generieren diese großen Tabellen, diese zwei Terabyte-Tabellen, die man sich dann runterladen kann. In diesen Tabellen, was wir verwenden, ist eine TMTO-Attacke, eine Time Memory Trade-off Attack. Und diese Tabellen helfen uns, das GSM in Echtzeit oder nahezu Echtzeit zu entschlüsseln, also innerhalb von einer Stunde.
Und das funktioniert bereits?
Wir generieren gerade diese Tabellen. Die sind noch nicht fertig. Wir verwenden einen Cluster von 100 FPGAs. Und dieser Cluster arbeitet für 120 Tage. Und der arbeitet noch und schwitzt noch.
Das heißt, da steht jetzt gerade irgendwo so ein Gerät rum und schwitzt und generiert diese Daten. Und das wird dann in ein, zwei, drei Monaten fertig sein?
Genau.
Und dann nimmt man diese Daten, packt die auf die Festplatten, schließt sie an diesen FPGA-Stein an, und dann hat man im Prinzip eine Maschine, die unter, zurückgreifen auf diese vorberechneten Tabellen. Dieses A5, auf Basis der bekannten mathematischen Schwächen, also auf Basis derselben bekannten mathematischen Schwäche, bloß mit einer neuen Methodik schneller entschlüsseln kann, als das bisher der Fall ist. Aber jetzt hast du ja gesagt, okay, dann sucht man sich einen Teilnehmer raus. Sieht man denn, wer, also wie sieht man denn, welches Telefon, ist das wieder die IMSI, die...
Genau, was übertragen wird im Klartext, ist deine IMSI und sogar deine E-Mail wird übertragen. Die E-Mail ist die International Mobile Equipment Identification. Das heißt, als Angreifer oder Mitlauscher weiß ich nicht nur deine, deine ID, sondern ich weiß auch, welches Mobiltelefon du verwendest. Ich weiß, welchen Typ von Mobiltelefone du sogar verwendest.
Weil das in der E-Mail quasi mit drin ist?
Das ist in der E-Mail-Nummer mit inkodiert. Diese zwei Nummern höre ich mit, sobald du ein Telefonat empfängst oder ein Telefonat machen möchtest.
Das heißt, in dem Moment, wo ich mich einbuche, wird E-Mail und IMSI im Rahmen des Authentifizierungsprozesses übertragen?
Leider ist es in den meisten Fällen so, dass der GSM-Standard sagt, dass es eigentlich nicht sein soll. Die E-Mail und die IMSI sollen nie übers Netz übertragen werden. Praktisch ist es aber so, nachdem wir mal nachgeschaut haben, dass es nahezu immer übertragen wird.
Das ist ja eigentlich gar nicht nötig, oder?
Nötig ist das gar nicht.
Dafür gibt es doch die Kryptographie.
Dafür gibt es die Kryptographie und eine temporäre Identifikation, die eigentlich dafür verwendet werden soll. Aber praktisch ist es so, dass in 95 % aller Fälle werden diese beiden...
Ist das eine Telefonsache oder eine Netzsache?
Das ist eine Netzsache. Das Netz sagt dem Telefon, übertrage mir doch bitte mal deine E-Mail und deine IMSI, weil ich möchte die gerne wissen.
Und die Telefone spucken das einfach aus?
Natürlich.
Und beim normalen Telefon ist das auch eine Funktion, die in diesen GSM-Chips mit fest eingebaut ist? Also selbst wenn ich jetzt sowas wie ein Open-Moco-Telefon nehme, die maximal freie Software und Controller haben, habe ich über diese Funktionalität keinerlei...
Macht keinen Unterschied.
Da müsste ich ja sozusagen erst mal jetzt hier mit eurer Software, die dann irgendwann auch senden kann vielleicht, und dem neuen Pocky-Briket an meinem Ohr, da könnte ich dann eben volle Kontrolle machen und sagen, irgendwie IMSI brauchst du nicht, schicke ich dir nicht.
Selbst das würde ich gehen, wenn die Basisstation sagt, ich möchte deine IMSI haben und das Mobiltelefon sendet es nicht, dann geht es nicht weiter. Das muss gesendet werden, wenn die Basisstation das haben will.
Wenn der GSM-Standard sagt, es soll nicht übertragen werden, warum gibt es überhaupt ein Paket dafür, dass man das hinterfragt?
Tja, gute Frage.
Ah, nächste Frage für dich. Gut, wir machen uns unsere Gedanken. Das heißt, um jetzt nochmal die Dimension von dem Ganzen zusammenzufassen, in ein paar Monaten wird es ein Gerät geben, was in Erlage ist, in beliebigen GSM-Netzen passiv, ohne dass man merkt, dass es da ist, alles mitzulauschen und kann gezielt mitgeschnittene Gespräche, weil man weiß ja, welche IMSI, welcher Teilnehmer, also vorausgesetzt man weiß diese IMSI, aber kann man wahrscheinlich relativ einfach machen, man ruft den einmal an, dann nimmt das Netz mit dem irgendwie Kommunikation auf, man weiß, der ist irgendwie der Gegner, dann hat man auch seine IMSI.
Genau, man kann ihn anrufen, man kann ihn sogar so anrufen, da gibt es spezielle Kommandos, dass man einen Mobilteilnehmer anrufen kann, ohne dass das Telefon klingelt. Das heißt, man kann also die IMSI und alle Identifikationen von jedem Teilnehmer rausfinden, ohne dass der Teilnehmer davon erfährt.
Man kann jemanden anrufen, ohne dass es klingelt?
Ja, natürlich. Es gibt spezielle Kommandos, mit denen kann man diesen Paging-Request senden und dem Mobiltelefon sagen, geh doch jetzt mal auf den Dedicated Channel, sende mir alle deine Identifikation. Bevor dann die Basis-Station sagt, ich möchte dich anrufen, sagt sie einfach, okay, war nichts, Entschuldigung.
Falscher Alarm.
Falscher Alarm, melde dich mal wieder ab.
Danke für Ihre Kooperation.
Danke für alle Informationen, das war's auch schon, danke.
Wenn ich jetzt frage, warum das drin ist, wirst du wieder mit den Schultern zucken. Super, GSM scheint ja echt ein Fass ohne Boden zu sein. Okay, das heißt, in dem Moment, wo man natürlich die Kontrolle über die Software hat, kann man genauso ein Request auch generieren. Hat der irgendwie einen speziellen Namen? Paging-Request?
Paging-Request, das kommt von einer Basisstation. Das ist halt der Rufrequest, wo ist denn Mobilteilnehmer, so und so, melde dich doch mal.
Okay, und in dem Moment reagiert er sozusagen auf seine Telefonnummer?
Auf seine temporäre ID, sagt er, ach, das bin ich ja. Und die Basisstation sagt dann, ja, send mir doch mal deine E-Mail, deine IMSI. Und das Mobiltelefon sagt dann, ach ja, klar, natürlich, hier sind sie.
Und da man weiß, dass dieser Anruf gleich kommt, weil man ihn selber ausgelöst hat, kann man eigentlich ganz gut draufhaken. Das heißt, man hat die IMSI und in dem Moment kann man auch gezielt danach lauschen und kann alles mitschneiden. Und in dem Moment, wo man schon anfängt mitzuschneiden, kann man im Prinzip auch schon anfangen, das zu dekodieren. Aber jeder Telefonanruf ist dann wieder mit einem neuen Schlüssel verschlüsselt. Also es reicht nicht einmal, etwas auszurechnen und dann habe ich das ganze Gespräch für immer, sondern ich muss für jeden Telefonanruf wieder von vorne anfangen.
Das ist richtig. Es gibt keinen ultimativen Master-Schlüssel. Es muss für jede Konversation, für jede Unterhaltung, für jede Textnachricht muss unser Gerät wieder neu cracken und eine Stunde investieren und dann kann man sich das wieder anhören.
Das ist ja irgendwie the end of the world as we know it.
Du hast zwei Sachen erwähnt. Du sagtest, es gibt zwei Sachen, die wir releasen. Das ist das Empfangsmodul an sich und dann das Crack-Modul. Das Empfangsmodul gibt es schon. Das können Leute sich heute schon runterladen, USAP kaufen und auch mal auf dem Beacon-Channel rauf schauen, was denn da so rumfliegt. Das Crack-Modul wird es dann in ein paar Monaten geben, wenn wir die Tables generiert haben.
Wie viele Leute arbeiten da derzeit dran?
Das ist alles Public, was wir machen. Es gibt gute Gründe, warum wir Public sind. Es gab viele andere Leute, die da schon Research gemacht haben. Diese Leute sind irgendwann nicht mehr aufgetaucht. Und da dachten wir, wenn wir Research darauf machen, auf GSM Security, machen wir uns doch von ersten Tag an komplett Public. Wir involvieren so viele Leute, wie wir können. Das heißt, auf unserer Mailingliste sind über 100 Leute drauf. Die wissen genau, was wir tun, was wir entwickeln. Das ist alles auf dem Wiki beschrieben. Und jeder kann es nachbauen und verifizieren.
Die Software, die da erstellt wird, hat die eine definierte Lizenz?
Momentan ist die Lizenz, dass jeder, der die Software, die released worden ist, ist unter der Lizenz von dem Typen, der es geschrieben hat. Das heißt, wir überlassen es dem. Es sei denn, er wählt sich... Ja, wenn er sagt, das ist jetzt unter der BSD-Lizenz, dann ist es unter der BSD-Lizenz. Wir machen da keine extra Lizenz obendrauf. Wir überlassen es dem Entwickler, der dieses Modul geschrieben hat, unter welcher Lizenz er es gerne releasen möchte. Und genauso ist es auch. Wir suchen immer noch Leute, die Interesse haben, da mitzuhelfen. Es gibt noch genug zu tun.
Was für Leute sind da so gefragt? Vielleicht sind ja hier unter den Chaos-Radio-Express-Hörern schon ein paar Leute, die ganz große Lauscher aufhaben?
Ja, also natürlich immer Leute, die gerne mal was ausprobieren, was andere Leute nicht gemacht haben. Aber generell Leute, die sich mit FPGAs auskennen, sind immer gerne willkommen. Leute, die es mit GSM und dem Protokoll auskennen. Leute, die sich mit GMSK-Modulation und Demodulation auskennen, wie Teruel-Algorithmen, wenn das mal jemand gehört hat. Das ist der GMSK-Demodulationsschritt für GSM. GSM, die Signale sind mit GMSK moduliert.
Frequenzspezies, sozusagen. Ja, na das klingt ja so interessant wie beunruhigend. Also im Prinzip kann man feststellen, das GSM-Netz ist heute real schwer abhörbar. Es ist schon mal grundsätzlich eigentlich kaum gesichert. Es gibt da, wie in allen anderen Telefonnetzen, auch keine End-to-End-Verschlüsselung, sondern das endet schon am Ende der ersten Funkstrecke. Und darüber hinaus ist das, was verschlüsselt ist, nicht unbedingt immer verschlüsselt, auch wenn man denkt, dass es das gerade ist. Und selbst wenn es verschlüsselt ist, sind die dort eingesetzten Algorithmen so schwach, dass man davon ausgehen kann, dass in unmittelbar bevorstehender Zeit alles mehr oder weniger in Echtzeit abhörbar ist. Das gilt dann aber auch für SMS, oder?
Das gilt dann auch für SMS. Und wir sind ja alles Leute, die sowas nur machen, weil wir Interesse daran haben. Wir machen das abends, wenn wir gerade nichts anderes zu tun haben. Das ist nicht unser Job, jetzt GSM auseinanderzunehmen. Da muss ich natürlich fragen, wenn es jetzt in der Vergangenheit schon Leute gab, die es mal Vollzeit gemacht haben, die können das schon seit Jahren. Wir machen das ja nur, um nochmal wirklich den Leuten zu sagen, hey.
Also du glaubst, dass die Arbeit, die er da macht, im Prinzip schon mal irgendwo getan wurde?
Ich bin mir sicher, dass irgendeine Agentur oder eine Firma solche Geräte vertreibt, mit denen man kommerziell GSM abhören kann. Die IMSI-Catcher ist ein gutes Beispiel. Und Rot und Schwarz vertreibt den anderen Firmen auch. Und was wir halt machen, unser Ziel ist es, den Leuten zu sagen, hey, GSM ist wirklich unsicher. Es wurde 98 schon gebrochen. Es ist jetzt wirklich Zeit, dass der GSM-Apparater mal die Verantwortung übernimmt und das nicht sicher macht.
Gibt es denn eine Fallback-Lösung, dass ein neuer Algorithmus verwendet wird?
Ja, die Fallback ist UMTS oder 3G. Da funktioniert es wieder anders. Da müssen neue Attacken geschrieben werden. Da hat sich noch keiner darum gekümmert. Da gibt es aber jetzt auch die ersten Leute, die da mal das anschauen und da mal ein bisschen versuchen, was da auszusehen.
Das heißt, bei UMTS kommen neue Verschlüsselungsalgorithmen und vielleicht auch generell andere Mechaniken zum Einsatz? Oder ist das sehr ähnlich zu GSM?
Nein, das sind alles neue, schöne Protokolle. Die wurden auch nicht unter Geheimhaltung entwickelt, sondern die wurden von Schritt 1, wo haben das GSM-Konsortium gesagt, wir möchten gerne, dass alle wissen, wie diese Algorithmen funktionieren. Dementsprechend wurden die auch verifiziert und verbessert. Das sieht schon schwerer aus. GSM oder UMTS fängt ja gerade erst an. Das geben wir noch ein paar Jahre, vielleicht findet da doch jemand was.
Was natürlich nicht heißt, dass GSM nicht schon die gleichen anderen Nachteile erbt von GSM, wie an der Basisstation des Schlussmesserverschlüsselung, das ist da wahrscheinlich genauso.
Das ist genauso.
Nur auf der Luftschnittstelle selber sieht das erst mal anders aus und da muss da noch ein bisschen mehr drüber nachgedacht werden.
Genau.
Ja, das war doch mal ein ordentlicher Überblick. Also wer Lust hat, bei dem Projekt mitzuarbeiten, der schlägt dann wonach in diesem Wiki?
Das ist bei wiki.thc.org/gsm. Und dort findet man Informationen, die man auf eure Mail-Nest draufkommt. Und dort sagt man einfach mal hallo und schaut, was es zu tun gibt.
Okay, so wird dann die Arbeit verteilt. Ja, Steve, kann ich nur sagen, vielen Dank. Es war jetzt ein sehr knackiger und umfangreicher Überblick über GSM. Den Hörern lässt sich eigentlich nur noch sagen, alle Fachbegriffe, die dir gefallen sind, wie immer, findet ihr die Links auf der Webseite auf chaosradio.ccc.de und natürlich auch in den Lyrics in der mp3-Datei, die ihr euch gerade heruntergeladen habt. Wenn ihr noch Anmerkungen habt, ihr seid immer gerne gesehen auf unserem Blog unter blog.chaosradio.ccc.de oder ihr schreibt ein bisschen was rein in unser Wiki, wiki.chaosradio.ccc.de oder schickt uns einfach eine E-Mail, chaosradio.ccc.de. Ja, so, und jetzt bleibt mir eigentlich nur noch zu sagen, danke, Steve, für die Ausführung. Gern geschehen. Ja, okay. Und ja, dann sagen wir Tschüss, oder? Bis dann, tschüss.